why are we going there the Denver MCA
wants me to create a new piece haven't
heard from them in years and when we
realized that you'd both be all needless
to say they were very excited Lenny and
easy son what did I tell everyone what
is this as a shirt honey and you need to
wear it or they vent homework well you
have to do is hand out these fake
coupons huh the chicken sandwiches and
when we're doing that Baxter film all
the people at the counter demanding a
Greek food then I rally the angry
customers I get them storm the counters
it'll be a thing of beauty I don't think
this is a good idea that's not a good
idea what are you talking about it your
mom it's gonna be fun like old times
you're gonna be brilliant yeah what
about when they recognize Annie we
better disguise Annie's gonna wear a
disguise that I dang it Baxter yep stay
out of this okay tabloids get a hold of
this it will be terrible for me a clear
i hears you shouldn't be in that
business anyway well please don't say
that you can edit for 20 years but you
got to show for it bunch of crap movies
in a tampon commercial it'd be nice was
it not a tampon campaign it was absorb
all the good things in life and leave
the rest of us okay
he's trying to make a living no I'm
giving you an opportunity to the artists
okay we've been over this atb you're
still artist please don't call us a and
B mom please don't cause artist Jimmy
Haleb I'm sorry our popcorn flicks and
faxed azim yeah I wouldn't it's not our
garbage dad Caleb can I just say you
forget I've seen the reviews of the
masterpieces your mama been churning out
no this he needs to hear this No all
right let's talk about the water balloon
thing huh yeah let's talk about the the
disastrous wife abusive look at least
and then oh my the epileptic attack I
don't get it we get it the pieces aren't
the same without you we'd or not you'll
know they're not know that's my goodness
shove it up your ass we don't need you
your mother and I will do it ourselves
we've done it that way for years we're
trying to be nice but you might want to
feel part of it again but the hell would
you both
you